bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce 30 août face à la grande
distribution et regroupement interne qui
s'y opèrent les producteurs de lait
comme ceux de fruits et légumes
manifestent leurs inquiétudes le
président des finisseurs luc guyau est
notre invitée à marseille plusieurs
milliers de poubelles s'étale dans deux
arrondissements de la ville depuis deux
semaines l'armée pourrait apporter des
moyens personnels pour évêques des
stocks de déchets
la population du timor oriental en
indonésie est manifestement participer
ou à massivement participer au vote pour
accéder nous en l'indépendance malgré
toutes les menaces et violences récentes
chacun veut la meilleure école pour son
enfant mais pas question de reproduire
des inégalités sociales exemple à
sucy-en-brie une deux établissements ont
décidé une rentrée concert pré rentrée
télévisée sereine pour france
télévisions tous les détails à la fin de
ce journal sur les nouveaux programmes
de france 2 après les producteurs de
fruits et légumes ce sont les
producteurs de lait qui concrétise dans
leurs manifestations multiples
l'avertissement lancé par les
organisations syndicales selon lequel la
rentrée sera chaude
les plus virulents étant ceux qui
réclament la libération du syndicaliste
agricole josé bové de la confédération
paysanne celui-ci incarcéré après la
destruction d'un mcdo dans l'aveyron
fera l'objet de maints d'une décision de
la cour d'appel de montpellier sur sa
demande de mise en liberté
mais aujourd'hui les producteurs de lait
de seine maritime ou de poitou charentes
commençait une semaine de manif avec
l'intention de rencontrer les
transformateurs et les distributeurs
pour tenter d'enrayer la chute des prix
alors pour bien comprendre ce qui se
passe en matière de prix dans la filière
du lait c'est à dire de la vache aux
rayons d'une grande surface
l'explication florence griffon avec
philippe deslandes
petit matin en pleine campagne normande
gilles chevalier va traire ses quarante
vaches le coeur un peu plus lourd que
d'habitude ce mois ci son revenu a chuté
de 1200 son unique client un producteur
de camembert lui a envoyé une facture
amputé de 5 centimes par litre de lait
il a du mal à confondre le marché des
produits laitiers difficile en europe
cependant depuis quelques mois par
contre nous ne nions pas le pouvoir
exorbitant de la grande distribution sur
les transformateurs et que la grande
distribution en faire un véritable
raclée tacle au niveau de la filière en
fait cette baisse des prix a été imposé
par tous les industriels aux producteurs
la raison est simple les crises russe
puis asiatiques ont réduit les
exportations de nombreux produits
laitiers
ceux ci ont dû être bradés sur le marché
intérieur en plus les camemberts n'ont
plus vraiment la cote
il fait des crises alimentaires depuis
le début d'année il y as baisse de la
consommation des fromages donc la
distribution ne fait que retracer l'état
du marché
en pratiquant des prix en baisse dans la
mesure où s arrêtera ce des débouchés
qui sont plus responsables
pas question de critiquer la grande
distribution s'est faite par peur des
représailles
toujours est il que ces signes ne
répercutent pas la baisse dans ses
rayons
le prix du camembert n'a pas diminué
depuis longtemps explications il n'y a
pas que le prix du lait dans le prix du
cadran
tout son travail tout sa publicité tout
son marketing toute sa recherche
le prix d'une once du lait cru les
camemberts de lait cru qui demande une
préparation plus importante soit plus à
30 ans lui restera certainement moins
qu'un prix un camembert premiers prix ou
n'empêche le camembert ce n'est rien
d'autre que deux litres de lait
transformés sûr on se rend payé par le
consommateur
le producteur en touche moins de la
moitié et l'inquiétude des manifestants
à l'école ne fait que se renforcer
depuis l'annnonce de la fusion de deux
grands groupes de distribution
commerciale carrefour promodès les
méthodes d'achat risque d'être encore
plus difficile pour les producteurs
enquête yann frottis pour les
agriculteurs en colère
les manifestations se succèdent et se
ressemblent leur cible
toujours la même les supermarchés accusé
de faire baisser les prix à outrance la
semaine dernière à marseille aujourd'hui
en charente maritime
ici les producteurs de lait ont voulu
vérifier les tarifs pratiqués
car en quelques jours les prix se sont
littéralement effondrés on accuse les
grandes surfaces entre autres de prendre
de grosses marges pour le peu
d'interventions qu'ils ont à faire sur
un litre de lait entre l'achat et le
redistribuer aux consommateurs une chose
est sûre aujourd'hui les gros
distributeurs font la loi sur le marché
apparu au début des années 60
l'hypermarché représente désormais près
de 1 5ème des défenses des français dans
le commerce de détail
rien que pour les fruits et légumes par
exemple les grandes surfaces concentre
60 à 65 % des ventes
un phénomène qui risquent encore de
s'amplifier avec l'alliance de casino et
promodès deux des plus grands groupes
français
leur but être encore plus performant en
unissant nos moyens on ira beaucoup plus
vite à la conquête du monde et donc en
étant numéro 2 directement numéro un
européen sur un marché qui est un marché
de consommation forte croissance ça
accroît les possibilités des deux
groupes
seul problème cette course en avant de
la grande distribution se fait souvent
aux dépens des fournisseurs et des
producteurs puissant concentrer les
distributeurs imposent leurs règles sans
craindre aucune sanction
chez pratique exigences de rabais délais
de paiement rallonge et autres abus
trois rapports parlementaires les ont
déjà dénoncé
un fournisseur ne peut pas se plaint de
ce comportement là s'il se plaint du
comportement d'un client qui fait 30% le
chiffre d'affaires il va perdre son
client 30% du chiffre d'affaires quand
une entreprise fait que deux ou trois
pourcent de marche c'est souvent les au
dépôt de bilan que de perdre ce client
selon ce rapport seuls les pouvoirs
publics pourraient aujourd'hui lutter
contre ces pratiques
la concentration elle se poursuit allier
casino et promodès distribueront
désormais un tiers des aliments achetés
en france
l'aiguillon bonsoir bonsoir pour nous
consommateurs c'est peut-être pas plus
mal qui est qu'un seul grand
distributeur lors dans l'immédiat
peut-être mais à terme cela peut être
dangereux aussi pour le consommateur
parce que lui perdra aussi la
possibilité de vous à choisir dans
certaines régions de france mais il
n'aura pas plusieurs grandes surfaces
et puis n'oublions pas que si demain il
ya plus de producteurs qu'ils soient
d'ailleurs agriculteurs artisanales
commerciales
il n'y aura pas ce lien direct entre le
consommateur et le producteur que les
consoles au moteur nous demande
aujourd'hui on nous demande de plus en
plus de qualités d'avoir cette relation
ce qu'on appelle la traçabilité du
produit pour qu'il ait traçabilité il
faut qu'il y ait le lien entre le
producteur et le consommateur et la
grande surface aujourd'hui les grandes
distributions la super concentration
tend à faire disparaître les producteurs
comme ça tu expliquer dans la porte
mais vous êtes allé voir le président de
la république aujourd'hui oui vous
souhaitez quoi vous souhaitez qu'avec le
gouvernement il met en place une
réglementation que président de la
république on a parlé bien sur des
problèmes d'actualité même si les
problèmes internationaux et ce problème
de la grande distribution est venu dans
la discussion
ce que nous souhaitons aujourd'hui après
c'est super concentration qui risque de
remettre en cause beaucoup l'économie
c'est que les pouvoirs publics jouent
pleinement leur rôle mais ça veut dire
quoi contrer fort alors quand c'est à
dire de le mettre des règles précises
dans le cadre du rapport entre les
producteurs ou les transformateurs et
les distributeurs
c'est à dire qu'un prix c'est un prix et
non pas un prix moins une remise qui
peut être mis sur la facture et ensuite
encore par la suite une autre mise
éventuelle mais taverne et en économie
de marché ne peut pas aimer arrivèrent
comme inventé mais comment voulez vous
que dans une entreprise on puisse gérer
durablement l'entreprise avec des
emplois avec de la matière première
si le contrat qui est passé entre deux
partenaires n'est même pas respecté
sans parler que aujourd'hui ces
rassemblements d'entreprise aussi
importante qu'elle soit vont faire payer
aux producteurs le mariage dans la
corbeille il faudra que demain parce
qu'on s'est regroupée et que l'on puisse
faire un petit cadeau comme on le fait
aux anniversaires
ça n'est pas tenable et je crois que
c'est pas la grande distribution tant
que tel qui est remise en cause dans
cette affaire de société et c'est la
démarche de la grande distribution avec
ses fournisseurs
ce n'est pas normal que la valeur
ajoutée ne soit pas mieux partagée
est-ce qu'il faut mettre en place des
systèmes de partenariats directs avec
certains distributeurs
alors dans certains endroits cela existe
et cela est un peu naissant il faut sans
doute avoir des partenariats beau lui
dire elle y est favorable
favorable à condition que ces règles
soient respectées et si qqun impasse un
contrat avec n'importe quel que soit le
distributeur pourquoi pas mais à
condition que les règles soient
respectées
et quand monsieur charrier disais tout à
l'heure une entreprise qui à 30% de son
chiffre d'affaires avec une grande
centrale d'achat si demain la grande
centrale d'achat veut le faire chanter
en lui disant maintenant mais c'est trop
cher il faut changer le packaging enfin
plein de choses comme cela
il ne peut pas choisir il est obligé de
se soumettre
car il ne peut pas dire demain à ses
producteurs ou à ses employés écoutez
j'ai perdu le marché on ferme parce que
c'est souvent que les derniers pas
jusqu'à demander des prix minimes prix
minima dans certaines dans certaines
situations cela pourrait se concevoir
parce que n'oublions pas que lorsque les
entreprises n'ont pas le droit de vendre
en dessous de d'un prix qui est le prix
au minimum d'achat mais les producteurs
à certains moments lorsqu on leur paye
leurs produits 50 % en dessous de leur
coût de revient et de les fruits et
légumes cet été c'est souvent ce qui
s'est passé les producteurs ils ont
leurs revenus qui est remise en cause
mais surtout l'existence même de
l'entreprise alors si le consommateur
veut avoir la durabilité de cette
relation avec des producteurs il faut
qu'ils pensent que le producteur il doit
pouvoir vivre aussi
vous avez annoncé une rentrée chaude est
ce que c'est parce que vous êtes sentie
dépassée par la confédération paysanne
qui était plus en avant dans la
revendication n'ont pas du tout puisque
la prévision de rentrée chaude était
bien avant que la confédération paysanne
fasse quelques actions à ceux qui mènent
les principales actions en ce moment non
pas du tout en réalité nous avons mené
beaucoup plus d'action que n'importe qui
cet été sur les fruits et légumes sur le
lait
il comprit même dans les mcdo mais nous
n'avons peut-être pas mener des actions
violentes qui ont retenu l'attention et
les médias nous nous souhaitons
respecter les biens les personnes autant
qu il se peut alors quand nous avons dit
que la rentrée se réchauffe c'est parce
que justement je sentais que des nuages
s'amoncelaient sur le lait sur les
fruits et légumes sur la volaille
autant d'éléments qui font que les
agriculteurs sont inquiets aujourd'hui
les agriculteurs sont plus inquiet sur
le manque de lisibilité de la politique
agricole ne savent pas très bien où on
va depuis en plus comme on leur parle de
mondialisation
j'ai entendu monsieur bernard dire on va
conquérir le monde sait bien qu'au cas
vers le monde mais il faudrait quand
même penser à ceux qui sont sur le
terrain qui font vivre la france qui
font vivre les régions qui maintiennent
l'emploi qui font la politique de
qualité et je crois que c'est cela que
nous voulons dénoncer aujourd'hui vous
vous souvenez josé bové le le
syndicaliste agricole la confédération
paysanne qui est emprisonné josé bové a
pris ses responsabilités d'action
syndicale m'a rien demandé et quand il a
pris ses responsabilités qui ne sont pas
les miennes il a pris ses
responsabilités et les assumer avec son
organisation mais lui c'est lui ou c'est
vous lui c'est lui ou c'est nous comme
cela était par le passé lorsque nous
avons eu nous aussi des situations
difficiles on nous a plutôt appuyé sur
la tête je rappelle qu'à certains
moments on m'a dit au début de l'année
lorsqu'il ya eu quelques actions un peu
un peu dur mais qui n'avait rien à voir
avec de la destruction que je ne
condamnait pas à mes yeux ça désapprouvé
simplement mêmes personnes qui l'ont dit
à l'époque qu'aujourd'hui soutiennent
les violences jeu du mal à comprendre
merci le guyot a marseille la collecte
des déchets est effectué à 40% par des
sociétés privées ou nombre de quatre se
sont des éboueurs de l'une de ses
sociétés qui se sont mis en grève depuis
deux semaines provoquant des
entassements de poubelles impressionnant
dans deux arrondissements marseillais la
grève porte sur les conditions de
travail et le nombre d'emplois devant
l'impossibilité de trouver un accord des
soldats pourraient venir prêter leur
concours pour vider les poubelles mais
ce soir la principale revendication des
éboueurs ayant été acceptée le conflit
pourrait je dis bien pour s arrête à
marseille le marché des ordures
ménagères demeure sur ce récurrente de
problème
reportage jacques cardoze et
jean-françois giorgetti
il était révolté par une possible
intervention de l'armée
mais les salariés de l'entreprise bronzo
viennent d'obtenir satisfaction sur une
partie leurs revendications depuis ce
matin ils ont été rejoints par les trois
autres entreprises privées chargées du
nettoyage à marseille le privé assure
ici 40% de la collecte des déchets le
public 60% selon les syndicats cette
crise était prévisible car en juin
dernier
la ville aurait négocié selon eux
l'ensemble des contrats trop justement
la source du problème c'est que les
marchés sont passés de façon à obtenir
des coups les pubs sans regarder la
qualité offerte et surtout le respect du
cahier des charges et à chaque fois
quelle que soit la nature des contrats
passés entre une collectivité
territoriale une ville et des
entreprises
ça se répercute d'une part sur
l'organisation du travail sur ces
conditions et sur le nombre de salariés
appelés à effectuer le cahier des
charges dans les rues de la ville plus
de 3000 tonnes d'ordures ménagères
s'entassent encore aujourd'hui certains
commerçants estime même avoir perdu ce
week-end 10 mille francs de chiffre
d'affaires
noël 93 les marseillais ville exactement
le même conflit en fait c'est le cas
tous les cinq ans depuis 20 ans lors de
la renégociation des contrats cette
année la mairie un ami qu'il fallait
deux chargeurs part belle mais à ce
moment là les patrons ont supprimé
beaucoup plus de camions voilà et on est
de nouveau dans le même compliqué tête
de notre point de vue un look totalement
prévue ce soir le président de
l'entreprise bronzo a finalement accepté
une partie des revendications de ses
salariés mais marseille va devoir encore
patienter quelques heures avant de
retrouver son vrai visage
concernant la baisse des impôts un
sondage publié ce matin dans le journal
le parisien vient quelque peu douché
l'enthousiasmé manifesté par les
socialistes lors de leur université
d'été à la rochelle selon ce sondage 64%
des français ne font pas confiance au
gouvernement pour la baisse des impôts
même si 47% d'entre eux sont satisfaits
de l'action menée par lionel jospin et
dans ce même journal le parisien
l'ancien commissaire européen et ancien
premier ministre madame edith cresson
est mis en cause de nouveau pour sa
gestion au sein de l'institution
bruxelles des rapports auraient été
antidaté pour justifier l'activité de
l'un de ses collaborateurs de l'époque
commentaires joël bruandet la sphère
cresson une des affaires à l'origine de
la démission de la commission européenne
en mars dernier déjà à l'époque le nom
de rené berthelot apparaît régulièrement
l'homme est un ancien dentiste de
châtellerault c'est un ami de longue
date d'edith cresson et lorsque celle ci
arrive à bruxelles
elle fait tout naturellement appel à
ceux proches je lui ai demandé de me
faire rapport sur un certain nombre de
dévolution de la recherche en france et
j'avais besoin de quelqu'un en qui j'ai
confiance que je connaisse qui avait
travaillé d'ailleurs pour moi avant
précédemment dans d'autres fonctions
ainsi entre 95 et 97
rené berthelot aurait rendu une dizaine
de notes en qualité de visiteurs
scientifique mais ces rapports ont ils
vraiment existé c'est la question que
soulève le journal le parisien à l'appui
ce document censé prouver que berthelot
a bien rendu un dossier le 18 mars 1997
seulement voilà les ordinateurs de la
commission font apparaître à chaque
impression
la date de création du fichier ici 1998
soit près d'un an après la part
sion du rapport controversé dans
l'entourage de l'ancien premier ministre
on affirme que tout cela pourrait
s'expliquer par des raisons techniques
et l'on s'en remet à lenquête une
enquête confiée au service antifraude de
l'union européenne résultat final à la
mi septembre
coïncidence ou pas c'est aujourd'hui que
parlement européen commence ses
auditions des membres de la nouvelle
commission européenne dirigée par romano
prodi et les parlementaires qui se
remarient monopole à cette occasion
montrer qu'ils ont vraiment tous les
pouvoirs c'est la raison pour laquelle
cette rentrée est pas tout à fait dans
très ordinaire pour les dix neuf
commissaires européens
cette rentrée commence en effet par un
grand oral ce n'est pas une formalité
pour y avoir assisté à quelques années
et aujourd'hui c'était l'espagnol de
yola de palacio vice-président de la
commission chargé des relations que le
parlement tout rire le banc elle était
interrogée sans ménagement sur une
affaire de fraude alors qu'elle était
ministre de l'agriculture dans son pays
mais hélas plus apparemment rassuré les
parlementaires et jeudi prochain ce sera
au tour de pascal amis nouveau
commissaire français est chargé des
relations extérieures et les
parlementaires européens bien
l'intention de poser quelques questions
alors qu'il était chef de cabinet
lorsque président jacques delors
assurait la présidence de la commission
européenne
le reprocheraient quelques négligences
ensuite lundi prochain ce sens retour de
michel barnier mais c'est un nouveau
venu sur la scène européenne
rappelons qu effectivement que vous le
disiez que le traité d'amsterdam donne
beaucoup plus de pouvoir parlement
européen qui entend user afin d'éviter
toutes les dérives qui ont contraint la
commission précédente a démissionné
alors le vote sera connu le 15 septembre
et on saura si le parlement européen a
donné quitus à la commission ils devront
travailler ensemble rld aurait peut-être
le blason des communes les deux
institutions qui en ont bien besoin
merci et se marie en indonésie et au
timor oriental malgré les violences et
les intimidations la population a très
massivement participé à la consultation
électorale sous contrôle des nations
unies des résultats de ce vote en faveur
ou non de l'indépendance ne seront pas
connus avant une semaine
commentaire jérôme baugnies c'est avec
un ouf de soulagement que les
fonctionnaires des nations unies ont
clos aujourd'hui le scrutin de tous les
dangers au timor-oriental l'un d'entre
eux un employé local a été mortellement
poignardé à la sortie d'un bureau de
vote mais les observateurs
internationaux
tendez à pire après les violences des
quatre derniers jours qui ont fait neuf
morts
aujourd'hui rien n'a pu arrêter
l'enthousiasmé populaire ils étaient des
milliers à se bousculer devant les
bureaux de vote attendant souvent plus
de quatre heures pour accomplir pour la
première fois dans l'histoire du
timor-oriental ce geste qui peut leur
donner l'indépendance
je suis très heureux car c'est la
première fois que je participe et que je
peux exprimer mon opinion dans un
référendum
il a fallu beaucoup de courage à chacun
pour venir voter malgré les provocations
des anti indépendantistes
ils ont tous l'espoir que ce référendum
mettra fin à 25 ans de violences depuis
l'abandon du timor-oriental par les
portugais et son annexion par
l'indonésie un quart de la population
deux cent mille personnes ont trouvé la
mort dans des combats ou des famines
aggravée par les déplacements de
population la forte participation 90%
laisse entrevoir une victoire des
indépendantistes
ce qui risquerait d'entraîner un effet
de contagion à d'autres îles de
l'archipel indonésien
l'impression aujourd'hui que timor
représente une sorte de modèle de ce qui
se passe dans le reste de l'indonésie
toute l'année dernière depuis la chute
du président soir tôt il ya eu des
émeutes dans beaucoup d'états qui eux
aussi sont tentés par l'indépendance
pour avoir plus de ressources qui
jusqu'à maintenant aller toujours au
centre même si l'indépendance est
souhaitée par la population elle devra
être approuvé par le parlement à jakarta
mais il est probable que cette journée
plus calme que prévu
or a lancé un processus irréversible
au kosovo les négociations ont repris
entre albanais et serbes d'orahovac son
présence des soldats russes et
néerlandais de la kfor pour tenter de
permettre le déploiement du contingent
russe dans cette ville des plantes
toujours bloqué par les albanais au nord
de la province à la limite d'une zone
serbe dans les enclaves de cha bras les
villageois albanais qui reviennent vol
petit à petit que la vie reprenne y
compris la vie scolaire et pourtant la
quasi-totalité des maisons de cette
ville ont été détruites
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux anne
consigny et andré y sera c'est comme si
une catastrophe naturelle s'était
abattue sur cha bras les 232 maisons ont
été concassés une par une réduite à ces
tas de débris il champ de ruines
émergent par ci par là une cuisinière un
reste de clôture les habitants qui sont
revenus ont planté une tente à la place
de leurs maisons mais il ne pourrons pas
reconstruire avant l'hiver alors le
maire haussmann rama a fait appel à
l'aide internationale
200 préfabriqués seront bientôt offerts
par des japonais mais il faudra aussi
acheter tout le reste oui migros coop
rendement de poêle à bois ou faire la
cuisine
on n'a plus rien la vaisselle par
exemple on en a seulement pour une
trentaine de familles devant sa maison
la seule qui tiennent encore debout
le maire explique comment le 29 mars
dernier les serbes ont attaqué le
village au mortier
chassons les habits ils ont pilonné
trois jours puis incendié les maisons et
terminer le travail au bulldozer
pourtant affirme haussmann ramalho checa
n'était pas présent dans le village les
deux nous ne voulions pas menacer les
villages voisins qui sont tous serbe
je ne voulais surtout pas de provocation
le secam à écouter ils ne se sont pas
installés dans le village
et pourtant mon chabrel là je puis
détruit kosovo alors finalement j'ai
peut-être
osman rama est un ancien professeur
figure d'un parti albanais modéré même
dans les ruines de son école sa
détermination reste calme il sait que
l'agresseur de belgrade a pris un coup
mais aussi de cette carte de la us avis
il y avait la croatie la bosnie la
slovénie et maman il ne reste plus que
la série bleue peu à peu son village
reprend vie 160 familles doivent revenir
cette semaine pour la rentrée scolaire
qui se fera sous une tente et voici le
premier magasin d'alimentation de chabre
si nous faisons aujourd'hui au serbe ce
qu'ils nous ont fêté hier dit osman rama
alors nous sommes pires qu'eux mais le
maire de cha brad mais aussi que les
discours modéré sont parfois dures à
tenir sur les champs de ruines en
allemagne presque un an après son
élection triomphale le chancelier social
démocrate gerhard schröder est plutôt
mal en point dans l'opinion publique de
la public fédéral aujourd'hui à
l'occasion du départ du président de la
bundesbank
monsieur schröder a voulu se montrer
optimiste malgré tout pour la croissance
économique de son pays
correspondance d'olivier werner heel
tenait d'une main de fer les rênes de la
bundesbank depuis six ans mais l'heure
de la retraite a sonné pour rendre ce
type mayer l'un des banquiers le plus
influent du loup il tire sa révérence
aujourd'hui et laisse la place à un
proche de gerhard schröder un sou tech
qui ne sera pas de trop pour le
chancelier dans la tourmente depuis ses
fans vacances rien ne va plus au spd les
dirigeants du parti au pouvoir se sont
entredéchirés tout l'été c'est la guerre
à gauche entre les modernisateurs et les
traditionalistes guerre h roller se
montre incapable de trancher cette
querelle dans sa propre famille
politique des ministres des présidents
de région des députés commencent à dire
à voix haute
ils ne savent plus ce que veut grh
fraudeurs l'image du gouvernement est
atteinte
l'image d'une chancelier était le site
écornée et l'opinion des allemands s'est
retourné cet été allez vous encore voter
pour cet homme là écrit le stern la
vanité est jugée comme étant son plus
gros défaut on l'a vu ramé cet été en
italie des vacances gâchées par un
brouhaha politiques et médiatiques comme
on n'en a pas vu depuis longtemps
conséquence sa cote de popularité a
chuté de façon vertigineuse en l'espace
d'un an 2 56% à 23 %
six élections régionales sont au
programme ces prochaines semaines
elle s'annonce tout simplement
catastrophique pour le parti social
démocrate du chancelier en france dans
les ardennes où près de charleville
mézières à bourg-fidèle une usine de
retraitement de batteries seraient à
l'origine d'une pollution au plomb nous
avions déjà évoqué au mois de juillet la
bataille qui oppose les ouvriers de
l'usiné désireux de préserver l'emploi
aux habitants riverains et aux autorités
administratives soucieuse de
l'environnement
il ya aujourd'hui l'usiné a été en
partie ouverte
reportage et lending josé boulesteix
c'est une nouvelle vie qui commence pour
n'est lié cfia loin de bourg fidèle et
des querelles qui divisent ce village de
800 habitants loin surtout de sa
pollution au plomb moi je suis parti
parce que je sais qu'elles sont plombées
c'est pour ça que je suis parti pour
l'instant elles ont pas des maladies
graves tout ça c'est parce que c'est
pour l'avenir je sais que plus tard
elles peuvent avoir des maladies graves
à cause de ce top 6 pour moi le seul
moyen c'est de partir pour il était ça
je suis parti aujourd'hui un an après
les premières analyses les deux enfants
ont un taux de plomb dans le sang encore
bien supérieur à la norme
pourtant la gravité de cette
contamination est sous-estimée par le
maire du village et le directeur de
l'entreprise métal blanc il ya tout
juste un mois les salariés s'affronter
avec les membres de l'association locale
d'environnement ce matin la reprise du
travail s'est effectué dans le plus
grand calme en respectant la décision de
justice à l'heure actuelle donc
l'activité de l'entreprise en termes de
production ne va pas reprendre
aujourd'hui il nous reste encore
quelques travaux d'entretien de
maintenance a réalisé que tout le monde
se pose un tas de questions savoir quel
va être son avenir personnel
si l'entreprise jamais définitivement
car dans cette région fortement touchée
par le chômage
l'emploi reste la priorité ce qui serait
bien pour lui dire c'est qu'elles
reprennent maintenant cadre qu'elle
refonctionne normalement et que donc la
santé publique soit soit respectée qu'il
n'y a plus de problème de pollution à
rebours final mais beaucoup doutent de
la bonne foi de l'entreprise
son pdg espère pourtant en revirements
du tribunal de reims
il vient d'y déposer un dossier ces
documents prouvent rey après plus de
deux années de retard
la mise en conformité de métal blanc et
dans cette même rubrique quotidienne de
la pollution voici le spectacle d'une
tonne de poissons morts dans un affluent
de la garonne la baïse amont travaux sur
garonne les premières analyses n'ont pas
permis de localiser l'origine de cette
pollution une tonne de poissons morts
quarante mille kilomètres de câbles cela
méritait presque le livre des records
pour ce câble sous marin en fibre
optique mis en service commercial par
france télécom le nouveau câble relie 33
pays sur quatre continents
explication patrice pollet ce câble a
été posé en un temps record 18 mois
moins de deux ans pour dérouler au fond
des océans
quarante mille kilomètres de fibre
optique grâce à une douzaine de bateaux
spécialisés
c'est pour répondre aux besoins toujours
plus grand du téléphone et surtout à
l'explosion d'internet dont la
croissance est aujourd'hui de 100 % par
an que ce câble a été mise en plus
l'europe le moyen-orient
la chine et l'australie 33 pays et
quatre continents sont désormais relier
un fantastique trajet effectué par
quatre minuscules fibre optique pas plus
grosse qu'un cheveu la capacité maximale
est de 400 mille communications
téléphoniques simultanée c'est énorme
pour tous les pays et une sur une
un point maritime d'entrée le cap sous
marin vous permettra d'avoir des
capacités très haut débit avec un coût
d'accès très bas pourquoi le câble
plutôt qu'un satellite
la réponse est simple le câble optique
peut transporter 1000 fois plus
d'informations et sa durée de vie est
double par rapport aux satellites 15
les français qui téléphonent 67 millions
d'heures par an vers l'étranger
devraient trouver leur bonheur grâce à
ce nouveau moyen de communication pour
la rentrée scolaire officiel de la
majorité des élèves prévus le 6
septembre prochain bien légitimement
beaucoup de parents veulent dénicher le
meilleur des collèges tractations
passe-droit ou petites combines deux
principaux de collège dans le val de
marne à sucy en brie ont décidé de ne
pas se laisser faire
d'autant que la rumeur publique désigner
un peu vite le rétablissement de façon
très opposés l'un était pour les bons
l'autre c'était pour les nuls
reportage sébastien leguay avec eric de
l'agneau le principal du collège du fort
est un guide convaincant aux parents et
aux simples visiteurs il scelle vendre
son établissement
tous les midis pendant deux heures à
l'heure du repas tout est ouvert et on à
l'accès au stade match de football match
que le basketball avec les animateurs
donc un cadre de j
extérieur en tout cas qui est qui est
agréable qui est rare en banlieue
parisienne
c'était tablissements un toujours eu
mauvaise réputation à sucy en brie
il ya le bon collège celui du parc et le
moins bon celui du fort
pourtant les taux de réussite au brevet
sont presque similaires souvent les
préjugés s'alimente des souvenirs des
parents qui ont connu des bâtiments
vétustes
c'est resté dans l'imagerie populaire
locale que le collège du fort et délabré
cassé or bas depuis on peut dire
maintenant bonne dizaine d'années c'est
non seulement c'est faux mais c'est
exactement le contraire
le collège du fort accueille une
population hétérogène 60% des élèves
viennent des cités de susi 40% des
quartiers pavillonnaires
devant cette mixité sociale certains
parents tentent d'échapper à la carte
scolaire
d'autres comme patrick pouvil et sa
fille font la sourde oreille aux débats
alarmiste je pense que sur mur 6180
parce que mason qui arrange pas dans
l'eau forme on arrête à dire c'est la
peur de racailles désole presque tous
les autres collèges nous en font
aujourd'hui pour la plupart qu'on n'est
pas on travaille tous les deux vont
souffrir et il ya déjà cette mixité
d'accord quand ils font du sport qu'est
ce que le football soit la chine sa
seconde pour qu'il ya cette mixité
en tous les cas donc ce n'est qu'une
continuité malgré ces différences
d'image le collège du parc refuse d'être
le concurrent du fort les principaux
d'établissements gèrent ensemble les
demandes de dérogation peut être j'ai
pas de nouvelles par rapport à m quand
elles sont farfelues ils ne font pas de
concessions nous sommes établissements
publics et entente en tant
qu'établissement public
nous sommes là pour accueillir tous nos
élèves l'ensemble lozère mais par
rapport à derek les règles une rigueur
qui porte ses fruits
les demandes de dérogations sont de plus
en plus rares cette année
messieurs les principaux noms n'ont reçu
que deux sports athlétisme au lendemain
des championnats du monde de séville où
l'équipe de france a recueilli trois
médailles
on cherche n'a pas désigné deux grands
vainqueurs là ça va de soi c'est
l'américain michael johnson
l'autre est moins connu mais très
influent commentaires de ligue 1 hier
soir michael johnson est devenu
l'athlète le plus titré des championnats
du monde
un dernier tour de piste avec ses
compères du 4 x 400 m haies l'américain
remporté sa neuvième victoire mondiale
un palmarès unique supérieur à celui de
carl lewis
non content de battre ses adversaires
michael johnson va aussi les records du
monde
déjà détenteur de celui du 200 m il est
devenu assez vie l'homme le plus rapide
sur 400 m des performances qui suscite
des questions ils rebat le record du
monde du 400 m en ayant il y a trois
semaines de cela dans un meeting
abandonné parce qu'il avait un claquage
ou une énorme contracture comment
fait-il pour guéret en trois semaines et
surtout comment fait-il pour continuer à
se préparer dans les meilleures
conditions pour battre le record du
monde
autre vainqueur autre interrogation
celle qui entoure john smith
à bientôt 50 ans il est l'entraîneur le
plus comblé de la planète
ses poulains se nomme maurice greene
marion jones swinger miller tous
vainqueurs à séville
ils sont fiers de leurs résultats comme
ils sont fiers du groupe auquel ils
appartiennent
hs et en anglais et lyng speed
intelligency gérer la vitesse avec
intelligence un programme controversé
qui fait appel à la sophrologie
certains évoquent un côté sectaire pour
qualifier les liens de john smith avec
ses athlètes
la vertu du silence c'est qu'ils te
donne de la force
si tu laisses ou transparaître c'est
comme perdre ton esprit est ton énergie
par contre quand une maîtrise ils
peuvent seulement essayé d'imaginer ce
que tu penses ce sera secret sauf pour
moi parce que je lis en toi vraiment je
rejette cette image de gourou que les
jambes prête parce que je suis le seul à
savoir où je suis et qui je suis je suis
en quête de connaissance depuis trois
ans marie josé pérec et membre de ce
groupe très fermé en vue des jeux
olympiques de sydney sa compatriote
eunice barber nouvelle championne du
monde pourrait la rejoindre
et pour la télévision l'événement
c'était aujourd'hui la présentation
officielle des programmes de rentrée de
france télévisions le président marc
tessier veux tu ne rentres et tonique en
cherchant la carte de la simplicité et
du direct derrière tout cela il ya des
magazines des fictions et le plaisir de
vous les proposer sur france 2 reportage
caroline nos draps et raymond schappler
une rentrée plutôt tonique pour france 2
avec un slogan la chaîne qui vous
ressemble
s'il n'y a pas de gros changement dans
la grille des programmes elle s'éternise
et et s'il doit y avoir modifications
elles auront lieu en douceur dans le
courant de l'année
pour certains il s'agissait d'une
première rentrée comme le nouveau
président de france télévisions marc
tessier michel drucker lui en est déjà à
sa 36e grille de programmes
mais l'élève est toujours aussi appliqué
et j'ai des livres neufs que je vais
couvrir un nouveau cartable
j'ai une nouvelle maîtresse
et michèle cotta que je connais depuis
très longtemps
il faut de grandes constantes dans le
service public et une grande continuité
à chercher tous les bouleversements trop
rapide tous les gens qui arrivent dans
une idée changfu je recommence moi je me
méfie toujours pour ceux qui aiment
qu'on leur raconte des histoires il y
aura dès demain le destin des scènes
fortes
puis la bicyclette bleue mais aussi la
trilogie de pagnol avec pour vedette
roja l'écrivain max en sélection 3,1
comparé à la simplicité d'étranges rêves
de chirel des autres au levain
d'humanité le tout portrait de ton
l'oncle émile basly un beau soleil parce
que ça le fatigue et de traîner son
ombre
côté divertissement michel drucker
n'aura plus qu'un invité dimanche
confronté au nouveau producteur bruno
masure pour qui c'est le retour sur le
service public
je pense qu'être caire nous a demandé de
venir avec la poivrière plus tôt donc on
va essayer de raisonner au maximum
l'invité qui sera déjà pas mal et
sauraient pas ce qui sera la pudeur dans
le domaine de l'information en a marre
abandonne d'un monde à l'autre pour
animer un nouveau magazine d'actualités
tous les dimanches de 12h à 13h si la
nouvelle grille des programmes se doit
d'être compatible avec le budget actuel
le nouveau président de france
télévisions a pour objectif de créer dès
l'an 2000 un service public renforcé
nous avons l'ambition d'être un des tout
premiers groupes de télévision en europe
nous sommes déjà mais nous allons nous
allons pratiquement prendre la tête et
je trouve que c'est cette image là de
force mais aussi de force créative qui
est l'image j'aimerais pouvoir laisser à
penser à proximité avec les
téléspectateurs chaleur et simplicité
tels sont les nouveaux mots d'ordre de
la rentrée
et sur ces belles perspectives je vous
rappelle les deux principales de la
formation développés dans ce journal
face à la grande distribution et au
regroupement interne qui lui perd les
producteurs de lait comme le fait le
green manifestent leur inquiétude lui
you pour l'iphone essor parle d'un
danger de monopole la population du
timor oriental a massivement participé
au vote pour accéder ou non
l'indépendance avec toutes les menaces
et violences récentes résultats du vote
dans une semaine
dans un instant la météo de ce fidèle
manqué à 20h55 les scènes forme maîtres
de l'orge la rediffusion mais pour bien
comprendre ce qu'il se sera la semaine
prochaine pour regarder dès ce soir à
0.55 ces derniers journal de la
rédaction présenté par florence du brass
demain 7h 50 dans les 4 vérités
yannick letranchant recevra nicole notât
secrétaire général de la cfdt puis à
13h02 trouverez laurence ostolaza et
emploi de cormery à demain 20h bonsoir
merci